goats chickens and geese all live
together in this farm it might look a
bit chaotic but it all makes sense the
baton of the pigeons wings functions as
ventilation cooling the air as a
consequence the rabbits have more babies
than the world if it were hotter
veterinarian Michael Babaji explains
this another innovation that is murder
fun the maison de pensar in Venice so
the many farmers will come to visit a
bad day is well known across West Africa
for his radical ideas we have 16 species
of livestock here the idea is to create
synergies that have villages can adopt
our methods because they are based on
traditional husbandry we have just
optimized this we show farmers how these
methods and help them make I think I
will be able to look after my animals
better with his methods and have a
better life for myself the average
weight of dr. BIR budget is adult pigs
is 150 kilos that is a lot for Africa
because the souls are well fed they have
between 8 and 12 piglets and 1 liter he
feeds his pigs with remnants from other
animals slaughtered on his phone it is
an easy form of recycling and it does
not cost a lot quite a long time dr. Bob
agita was something of an outsider and
been a agronomist was subscribed to
european-style mass industrial farming
rejected his ideas and excluded him from
academic circles
[Music]
it was imaginative for years and years
the professors thought that you must not
give different kinds of animals together
and now you have improved Romi I had
lots of problems with the university and
the Minister for 17 years but I stood up
today I was kept out of all seminars and
workshops on husband but that has not
rained that benna's largest university
though the agricultural science
textbooks which are from frost date from
the 1970s been has been independent for
six decades but the influence of its
former colonial ruler is still much in
evidence the university does not have
many computers and internet access is
not widespread
Luke dosa is a professor of Agriculture
he studied and taught in Germany and has
studied the different traditions of
animal husbandry Europe and Africa
he says the African model has a lot
going for it all tests books teach
industrial livestock production with
each specially held separately but
traditional methods are making a
comeback also in Europe many people are
very critical of factory farming
nowadays we are not interested in
intensive farming but in extensive
farming
estas dr. Bob agita sees this shift as
an endorsement of his approach which has
always considered the right one more and
more student of agronomy come to see him
and his farm
naki focus he finished University when
they graduate and come yet I have to
reprogram and reformat them so they
think like farmers the past calmly
family international aid organizations
are showing an interest in his methods
the UN's Food and Agriculture
Organization has expressed interest in
his work dr. Faberge is about to go on a
lecture tour to Congo Gabon Cameroon and
EJ the outsider has finally become a
real model